at the end of the house of dragon
episode 1 king advisory says to rhaenyra
that there's a great winter coming and
restaurants must stand together against
it and if they're to survive it the
targaryen must be seated on the phone
now this was a dream that was had by
aegon targaryen and he called the dream
a song of ice and fire king viserys then
hands his daughter the vilerian dagger
now this was a tiger that was actually
used to kill the night king so there's a
lot of foreshadowing done in the scene
to foreshadow and being the white
walkers in the winter come in and also
the dagger now what i find disappointing
about this scene is that the setup is so
great but then the actual payoff we get
in season 8 of the game of thrones this
is such a big letdown fortunately they
can't change any of that but it just
makes me wish what if what if we just
got a better season aid of game of
thrones which had an actual good payoff
which is being set up here because
honestly i really wanted to see like jon
snow versus the night kim because that
was set up in game of thrones itself but
never happened for whatever reason but
anyway that's pretty much everything for
this videos let me know your guys
thoughts on this in the comment section
below and if you haven't already please
do consider subscribing thanks for
watching guys